die ukraine aus den klauen des
russischen aggressors befreien wird ein
schwieriges unterfangen militärischen
politischen wirtschaftlich als
fluchtburg bietet sich die europäische
union an aber schützt sie wird nicht vor
putin und sichert sie die zukunft des
landes zwischen wunsch und wirklichkeit
gehört die ukraine in die eu jetzt in
der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns war die
gäste hier im studio katerina
alkohol ist bei uns sie kommen aus lief
aus lemberg in der ukraine ist es sind
übersetzerin leben seit einigen jahren
in berlin und sie sind auch gründern des
vereins kultur eine allianz ukrainische
organisation da sind
nichtregierungsorganisationen
ehrenamtliche organisationen die der
ukraine helfen und auch den ukrainischen
flüchtlinge die hier in deutschland
gerade in berlin sind erich fahrt ist
bei uns gerade general außer diensten
sie arbeiten heute als
unternehmensberater und dozent und waren
zu zeiten der bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel militär politischer berater der
bundeskanzlerin im kanzleramt
professorin nicole leiten hoff ist
politikwissenschaftlerin und leiterin
des
leibniz-instituts hessische stiftung
friedens und konfliktforschung in
frankfurt am main
und von der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik ist kai olaf lang bei uns sie
arbeiten in der forschungsgruppe
europäische union europa vor allem mit
dem schwerpunkt ost und
mitteleuropäische staaten also die
staaten die an russland und an die
ukraine unmittelbar grenzen in dieser
forschungsgruppe des der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik frau den hof
der eu beitritt würde nicht nur über das
schicksal der ukraine entscheiden
sondern auch über das schicksal von ganz
europa das hat die lenz geht der
ukrainische präsident neulich gesagt das
heißt also einen dauerhaften frieden
kann es in europa nur geben aus dieser
sicht wenn die ukraine tatsächlich
möglichst eng in die europäische union
eingebunden ist ist das richtig ich
würde da tatsächlich kein so eng nexus
ziehen aber ich denke dennoch dass die
ukraine in die europäische union gehört
und dementsprechend bin ich auch der
meinung dass es unbedingt jetzt im juni
dazu kommen sollte dass ihr der beitritt
also der kandidatenstatus für den
beitritt gewährt wird pro vita cool das
ist ja ein ganz langwieriger prozess
dieser beitritt es gibt kandidaten
status dann durchläuft man verschiedene
phasen der beitrittsverhandlungen 35
kapitel sind das insgesamt die türkei
seit 1963 auf dem weg in die europäische
union
in ihrem land ist die hoffnung groß dass
es zu diesem eu-beitritt kommt aber den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer klar dass das
lange jahre dauern kann
auf jeden fall ukrainerinnen ukraine
hoffen jetzt auf kandidatenstatus und
nicht auf das eu beitritt zu suchen auch
kein keine kurze wege und wollen auch
nicht skip entweder jugendritter sonst
seid und wir sind später sprechen wir
darüber viel weiter als
hier die öffentlichkeit der
öffentlichkeit bewusst ist also es geht
ja um die voraussetzungen auch genau
euro für einen bayern sind ja sehr
vielfältig sprechen wir auch noch an
erfahren und ihn hat er die ukraine
überfallen nicht weil er vor unseren
waffen angst hat sondern weil er das
westliche gesellschaftsmodell hast
dieser westen würde ja bei einem eu
beitritt der ukraine jetzt ganz nah und
zwar auf breiter front an die russische
grenze anstoßen was glauben sich der
kreml auf diesen beitrittswunsch
reagiert vor allen dingen auch die
aussicht darauf wenn es jetzt zu diesen
status des kandidaten für die ukraine
kommt naja die ukraine hatte den nato
beitritt und auch den eu beitritt in
ihrer verfassung auch festgeschrieben
und vor allem der nato beitritt war
natürlich aus russischer sicht ein
großes problem bei der eu kann man das
vielleicht anders sehen aber die eu hat
eben auch eine militärische
beistandsverpflichtung im artikel 42 und
aus russischer sicht ist das schon ein
thema das heißt man wird sehen müssen
nach das steht ja frühestens an nach
ende dieser ganzen kampfhandlung nach
ende dieses krieges
virus werden sich da positioniert und in
irgendeiner form muss man sie da
sicherlich auch nicht mit berücksichtigt
war sie spielen da eine rolle angela
merkel hat ja gestern auf dieser
veranstaltung als zum ersten mal nach
sechs monaten wieder aufgetreten ist
auch etwas dazu gesagt dass ich ja
damals den nato-beitritt der ukraine
verhindert hat das war ja ein wunsch der
amerikaner unter anderem aber wenn ich
sie jetzt richtig verstehe die russen
unterscheiden schon ein bisschen
zwischen eu nato oder ist das jetzt
durch diese beistandsverpflichtung auch
in vertrag für die eigentlich das
gleiche ja das muss man abwarten wir
wissen ja alle nicht wie sich die lage
entwickelt wir gehen ja wahrscheinlich
auf eine zeit zu eines kalten friedens
vielleicht sogar eine einer neuauflage
des kalten krieges mit einer vorne
verteidigung der nato die von finnland
beginnt über 200.000 kilometer
gemeinsame grenze mit russland wenn man
das in diesem kontext sieht dann ist so
eine eu-mitgliedschaft natürlich ja aus
der russischen sicht bleibt das
problematisch aber man weiss es ähnlich
es kann ja auch ein kalter frieden
werden mit einem großen konflikt
und in irgendeiner form doch wieder
politische gesprächsbereitschaft das
muss man abwarten er lange auch
innerhalb der europäischen union gibt es
ja durchaus skepsis gegenüber einem
beitrittskandidaten und späteren
mitglied ukraine wer ist da im
besonderen skeptisch naja es gibt die
länder wo wir schon seit langem eine
erweiterungsmüdigkeit eine fertig
feststellen länder die sich eigentlich
mental nicht mit den erweiterungsrunden
von 2004 2007 abgefunden haben dazu
gehört sicherlich frankreich dazu
gehören die niederlande wo es 2016 ein
referendum gab über das
assoziierungsabkommen mit der ukraine
das negativ ausgehen und das war nicht
binden das parlament hat das dann wieder
korrigiert letzten endes und es gibt
eine ganze reihe anderer länder wo wir
davon ausgehen können dass die bremsen
und der erweiterungsprozess das müssen
wir uns vergegenwärtigen ist einer wo
die mitgliedstaaten vom anfang bis zum
ende eine sehr hohe relevanz haben das
ist einstimmig in vielen phasen von der
verleihung des kandidatenstatus über die
eröffnung der verhandlungen über die
öffnung einzelner
verhandlungsprozess bis hin natürlich
zur ratifizierung also das ist in der
tat etwas was sehr stark zu sagen der
kontrolle der hauptstädte und liegt und
deswegen braucht man im grunde einem
neuen erweiterungs konsens dass der
linken also sehr viele steine noch im
weg bis zu einer endgültigen und
offiziellen mitgliedschaft vorteile ich
habs gerade schon mal angesprochen
ukraine und frieden in europa hin gerne
sehr eng zusammen diese bisherige
friedens und sicherheitsrat ist ja
geschichte die ist makulatur
durch den russischen angriffskrieg
möglicherweise wird russland ja auch je
nachdem wie dieser kriegsende kommt er
vielleicht auch nur ein waffenstillstand
sein oder einen großen konflikt also ein
eingefahrener konflikt ja nichts
wirklich löst
dann wird möglicherweise lange isoliert
bleiben in diesem europa wie muss man
sich hier das jetzt vorstellen gerade
die rolle der ukraine in der eu egal
jetzt in welchem status ob man mitglied
ein assoziiertes mitglied
welche rolle noch mal spielt da die
ukraine für den aufbau einer einer
friedensordnung und wird die auch durch
die ukraine und mit der ukraine
gesichert
also vielleicht das ist ganz gut dann
kann ich nochmal auf einen punkt aus der
ersten runde eingehen sie hatten ja
gesagt dass das sozusagen die
europäische union jetzt an die grenzen
russlands bayern heranrücken würde mit
einem solchen eu beitritt der ukraine
faktisch ist es aber so wenn russland
mit seinen plänen in der ukraine
durchkommt dann rückt russland auch an
das gebiet der europäischen union heran
also das ist eigentlich gar kein
argument und das macht einfach
vielleicht auch noch mal deutlich worum
es gerade geht es geht tatsächlich der
roben die ukraine zu einem
beitrittskandidaten für die europäische
union zu machen um tatsächlich zum einen
solidarität mit der ukraine und nicht
nur mit der ukraine wir reden ja
eigentlich faktisch über drei staaten
die auf mehr oder weniger gemeinsam den
antrag gestellt haben nämlich auch noch
über molder und auch noch über georgien
solidarität mit diesen starken die von
russland bedroht sind zu zeigen zugleich
in einer lage in der wir wissen dass
russland versucht diese länder weiter zu
destabilisieren
ihnen sozusagen ein mitte instrumente an
die hand zu geben den weg der
liberalisierung der demokratisierung
weiter voranzuschreiten und das wissen
wir aus der forschung wir wissen dass
wenn ein demokratisches bündnis eine
solche beitrittsperspektive eröffnet
dann kann sie die pro demokratischen
kräfte in dem land eben stärken sie
stärke gegen die autokratischen kräfte
und das ist es worauf es ankommt für die
zukunft wenn wir eine neue
friedensordnung waren wir brauchen
verlässliche partner die mit uns auf dem
weg der demokratie bleiben und deswegen
ist es auch so wichtig jetzt der ukraine
diesen beitritt also keine in das jahr
gestartet haben ja schon partner in der
eu mitgliedsländer wo genau die frage
von demokratie und rechtsstaat
zwei versteht das wird eher ein weiteres
problem ja auch machen mit das nicht
geklärt wäre es gibt ein schönes
stichwort im deutschen dass einem das
hemd näher ist als der rock wenn jetzt
manuell makro gerade ja schon
angesprochen worden ja jetzt mit den
osteuropäischen erweiterungen nicht so
viel zu tun hat weil das weit weg ist
von frankreich gefühlt weit weg
zumindest kann er jetzt auf die idee zu
sagen dann gibt es eben eine sozusagen
eine eu-weit namens politische
europäische gemeinschaft da dürfen alle
die mitglied werden die nicht wollen
oder nicht können oder noch nicht können
um den die eu also nicht mitglied der eu
sein können oder wollen das vereinigte
königreich soll dass ich wieder annähern
westbalkanstaaten die ja auch schon den
aufnahmeantrag gestellt haben und eben
auch die ukraine das ist ja eine gilt
die eine zwischenlösung ist das etwas
was die ukraine
zufriedenstellen wird es das erste oder
befürchten sie da dass diese idee von
makro die mitgliedschaft so etwas auf
die lange bank schiebt
ich sehe dass ich sehe diese
lebende defensive haltung der eu die
makro auch in meinen augen am besten
vertritt oder demonstiert
als eine destruktive haltung für die eu
also wenn wenn europäische kommission
setzt sich mit diesen feigenblatt
mit diesem komischen neuen worten aber
eigentlich die mitgliedschaft verweigert
also kandidaten schafft verweigerte
ukraine das wird ein schlag sei nicht
nur für die ukraine und nicht nur für
proeuropäische und demokratische kräfte
in der ukraine sondern auch für
demokratische und proeuropäischen kräfte
in der eu weil die eu mit der austritt
von großbritannien mit
problematischen beziehungen mit umgang
und mit an spannungen zwischen
baltischen staaten und
skandinavischen ländern und geben mag
und auch herr olaf scholz diese ganze
spannungen werden dadurch nur sich nur
verhärtet verhärten denke ich und das
ist wirklich keine lösung weil denn
diese dieser hinterhof da will keiner
hin das ist ja nicht einladen muss man
zur ehrenrettung von makro vielleicht
sagen er möchte vielleicht die union
nicht erweitern aber wenig vertiefen was
er übrigens bei manchen deutschen
politikern auch durchaus schrecken
verursachen könnte das aber ein anderes
thema erlangen wenn man das jetzt
sich anzieht diese überlegungen
kandidatenstatus oder möglicherweise in
diese politische europäische
gemeinschaft eu leid
das klingt natürlich jetzt gerade auch
aus sicht der ukraine aber auch der
anderen länder die da drin sein sollen
aber eigentlich am liebsten gern
vollmitglied werden klingt so ein wie
ein bisschen zwischen baum und borke ist
das aus sicht einer strategie die ja
möglichst viel integration möglichst
viel stärke für die europäischen staaten
zum ziel hat ist das negativ ist als
nachteilig ich denke der ansatz der
europäischen union sollte ambitioniert
und realistisch zugleich sein wir müssen
uns vergegenwärtigen dass der
kandidatenstatus allein relativ wenig
bringt das ist zunächst mal ein symbol
ein kraftvolles symbol aber es gibt ein
gewisses risiko dass es in so eine art
westbalkan situation hinein läuft ja wo
länder einen status haben aber im grunde
der ganze prozess stagniert das muss man
vermeiden
deswegen habe ich sicherlich keine
illusionen über die intention des
französischen staatspräsidenten der das
glaube ich eher als sozusagen dauerhafte
alternative sieht aber ich denke wir
sollten uns tatsächlich gedanken darüber
machen wie man zwischenlösungen
konstruiert die nichts zu sagen die
abstellkammer sein sollen sondern ein
fitnessraum sein könnten also im grunde
eine art nennen das mal neue
erweiterungs partnerschaft die länder
wie die ukraine sehr schnell an den
binnenmarkt nicht nur heran führen
sondern einbinden wo wir eine klare
energie und klimapolitische offerten und
wo wir auch eine starke
sicherheitspolitische komponente hätten
ich glaube das könnte dazu beitragen
dass diejenigen die bremsen und sagen
wir wollen nicht in etwas
hineinschlittern was wir nicht mehr
kontrollieren können dazu beitragen dass
die dann sehen naja wenn das
funktioniert in diesem zwischenraum dann
ist der nächste schritt auch nicht mehr
so riesig denn wir müssen und eines
vergegenwärtigen die ukraine startet ja
nicht von null und die ukrainische
regierung argumentiert nicht ganz zu
unrecht das assoziierungsabkommen und
das freihandelsabkommen hat dazu geführt
dass schon ein großer teil des akiko
militär des rechtlichen besitzstandes
der europäischen union dass jedes
künftige mit übernehmen muss tatsächlich
umgesetzt wurde er und man ist
vielleicht sogar schon ein bisschen
weiter als manche westbalkan staaten
also lange rede kurzer sinn ich finde
diese zwischenlösungen sind etwas
worüber man nachdenken sollte man darf
sie nur nicht so ausrichten dass dort
eine sackgasse ist und großbritannien
das eben raus ging und nicht mehr rein
will sagen in einen topf werfen mit den
ländern die mehr europa und nicht
weniger europa aber heißt das nicht dass
wir eigentlich beides brauchen also wir
brauchen auf der einen seite jetzt den
kandidatenstatus und das heißt eben
nicht irgendwie eine mitgliedschaft
light das heißt auch nicht eine
mitgliedschaft geschenkt sondern es
heißt dass es jahre dauern wird und
tatsächlich alle kapitel auch erfüllen
zu können und auf dem weg dahin braucht
es dann eben sozusagen andere abkommen
beispielsweise eine intensivierung der
östlichen partnerschaft in den einzelnen
sektoren um eben der ukraine und ich
würde auch sagen genauso georgien genau
so molder auf dem weg zu helfen und
genau so müssen wir auch daran arbeiten
und muss die europäische union daran
arbeiten dass die blockade im westbalkan
gelockert wird also nord mazedonien und
albanien
natürlich muss es auch da vorangehen
denn wir können nicht die ein sozusagen
auf der schnellstraße nach vorne
schieben und die anderen am
ausgestreckten arm verhungern lassen und
ganz ehrlich sicherheitspolitisch ist
lass das gebot der stunde darum geht es
jetzt diesen starken deutlich zu machen
sie gehören nicht nur nach europa sie
gehören in die europäische union und die
europäische union ebene den weg dafür
und ist bereit zu investieren
ich würde auf diesen aspekt gerne noch
eingehen der sendung da sind auch einige
andere staaten dabei die hier nicht
genannt worden sind erfahrt wenn wir
jetzt mal fünf bis zehn jahre in die
zukunft blicken es könnte ja tatsächlich
zu einem ja waffenstillstand kommen
diesen sogenannten großen konflikt also
ein eingefrorener konflikt der aber
nicht wirklich weiter führt
möglicherweise auch mit häufigen
waffenstillstands
vertragsverletzungen möglicherweise eine
waffenstillstandslinie ähnlich dem 38
grad zwischen nord und südkorea und
große oder teile der ukraine sind von
russland nach wie vor besetzt es ist
denkbar dass ein solches land mit der
europäischen union werden kann in diesen
status weil ja auch die europäische
union viel stärker noch in militär und
sicherheitspolitischer hinsicht sich in
den nächsten jahren
zusammenschließen und neu formieren wird
das ist eine berechtigte frage und
deswegen ist dieser französische ansatz
das was man kaum meint dieser
gesonderten regelung also die georgien
ukraine moldawien um fast schon nicht so
einfach vom tisch zu fegen also er hat
nachteile natürlich er kann dazu führen
dass man nicht vorwärts kommt aber es
bringt auch nichts die sind kandidaten
status zu verleihen und das als ein
symbol wert anzusehen wo danach nicht
mit nicht mehr viel kommen kann das
große problem bei georgien bei der
ukraine auch bei moldawien sind ja
diesen konflikt man muss davon ausgehen
und die russen operieren natürlich damit
in georgien haben wir südossetien
abchasien nicht wo sie eben zugriff
haben bei der ukraine wird das auch in
ihren seiner form sein ich glaube nicht
dass sie aus der krim rausgehen dem
donners verlassen ich weiß kann es mir
nicht vorstellen und eben weil da wir
haben wir das transnistrien thema nicht
und man muss sich darüber im klaren sein
wenn man diese länder aufnimmt das sind
natürlich gilt auch für die nato
letztlich spiegelbildlich dann
importieren sie dieses problem natürlich
in das bündnis rein und auch in die eu
reinigt und wir haben wie gesagt in der
europäischen union auch diese bündnis
verpflichtung nach artikel 42 absatz 7
und so ähnlich wie im nordatlantik
vertrag eben auch und das ist nicht
unerheblich nicht weil sie sie haben
dann praktisch die konfrontation linie
innerhalb europas nicht das muss man
schon sehen
also muss man den richtigen weg wählen
wir wissen aber nicht wie zukunft läuft
also wenn wir wirklich auf einen krassen
kalten krieg zu gehen
dann muss man das anders bewerten als
wenn es nur ein kalter frieden ist mit
1000 konflikts wo man noch doch noch
irgendwo politische drehte und kontakte
zu russland hat und haben muss was ich
für wahrscheinlich halte weil russland
ja auch nach diesem krieg nach diesem
schrecklichen krieg nicht verschwinden
wird wo es land ist eine nuklearmacht
die bleiben da also sie bleiben ein
faktor und auch für europa es geht gar
nicht anders das heißt wir haben in
diesen drei eu
beitrittskandidaten aber die interesse
an einem eu-beitritt haben in der aus
der schwarzmeerregion moldawien ukraine
georgien jeweils massive ungelöste
grenzkonflikte gleichzeitig eben auch
die frage wie wird russland sich
verhalten wenn man sich das jetzt mal
zusammen denkt es ist ungeklärt in
diesen drei ländern
gleichzeitig wird möglicherweise werden
die spannungen zwischen west- und
mitteleuropa und russland weiter
zunehmen noch mal die frage unter diesen
bedingungen wir reden ja jetzt darüber
ob die wie weit die ukraine an die eu
angebunden werden kann klingt das so wir
haben ja den titel wunsch und
wirklichkeit für die sendung eigentlich
eher nach wunsch und nicht nur realität
demnächst sollen die ukraine stärker zu
integrieren
also wenn ich mal so sagen dafür haben
auch innerhalb der europäischen union
bereits ungelöste konflikte also ich sag
mal griechenland zypern der türkei das
haben wir alles wir haben separatisten
innerhalb europas spanien denken sie an
katalonien denken sie an irland also die
europäische union hat als politisches
projekt erfahrung mit so etwas das ist
kein ausschlussgrund um in die
europäische union integriert zu werden
und bei der frage ukraine kommt es vor
allem darauf an ob wir eine unabhängige
regierung in kiew erhalten können oder
ob es russland gelingt tatsächlich die
ukraine doch noch niederzuringen und
dort eine statthalter regierung
einzusetzen wenn der boden ist dann ist
die europäische integration erst mal vom
tisch das ist vollkommen klar aber das
ist die entscheiden fragen und nicht die
ob es sozusagen grenzkonflikte geht
damit hat die europäische union für war
genügend erfahrung wobei dieser
grenzkonflikt vielleicht noch ein
bisschen gefährlicher sind als die die
sie jetzt noch genannt hat von von
ländern innerhalb der eu wenn man jetzt
vielleicht vom balkan mal absieht ich
würde dir nochmal auf die ukraine kommen
also auf die die probleme die die
ukraine er hat sie hat ja jetzt mal als
stichworte es gibt dort ein
demokratiedefizit das wird wurde jetzt
versucht in den letzten monaten zu
beheben auch durch den neuen präsidenten
selensky es gibt den vorwurf dass es in
diesem land auch massive korruption gibt
vielleicht auch noch überbleibsel aus
der organischen herrschaft dann wurde
der ukraine oft vorgeworfen man hätte
die russische minderheit in den gebieten
die sie bislang beherrscht hat in donezk
und lohans eigentlich die autonomie
verweigert und die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung ist eben auch nicht so dass
der beitritt der ukraine jetzt sofort an
steht
das steht ja einer schnellen
mitgliedschaft auch einige was kann die
ukraine von sich aus tun ich weiß die
frage ist natürlich jetzt insofern etwas
schwierig weil sie immer mit in einem
krieg ist von sich aus tun diese
defizite zu beseitigen weil die werden
ja in diesen ganzen kapiteln bei den
beitrittsverhandlungen besprochen werden
es gilt jetzt sehr viele fragen die sie
angestoßen haben
sie dürfen sich einmal
auf ließ die ukraine einen sieg gehabt
also ein demokratiedefizit defizit
integrieren daran das ist mir nicht
bewusst also es ist eine lebendige
demokratie mit ehrlichen sauberen wahlen
wo auch keine rechte partei im parlament
geschaffen hat
um eine autonomie geht es gar nicht denn
es geht nicht um separatisten es geht um
russisch angeführte
kämpfer die eben aus dem osten und süden
des landes kämpfen
es gibt länder hat die unter
ukrainischer herrschaft gelang
aber es gibt auch eine ganze reihe von
von rassischen minderheiten in luhansk
internets ist es zum kriegsausbruch kram
und da wurde ja immer wieder auch von
von westeuropäischen staaten vorgeworfen
den müsste man eigentlich autonomie
gewährt ich will jetzt von der zeit vor
dem krieg das war ja auch ein vorwurf an
die ukraine sie würden minderheiten
russischen minderheiten keine autonomie
gewähren das ist eine diskussion die mir
nicht bewusst ist es gibt da keine
russische minderheiten es gibt auch es
gibt viele nationalitäten die
ukrainische staatsbürgerschaft besitzen
und
es geht nicht darum dass man in die
polnische minderheit autonomie gewährt
oder in transkarpatien der ungarischen
autonomie es gab nie diese gespräche
wirklich und es ist auch nicht
bestandteil
des konflikts in der ukraine und
wirtschaftliche entwicklung
ist also ist eigentlich glaube ich gar
nicht so
schlecht wenn man die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung in den kriegszeiten ansieht
ist eigentlich besser als man sich
erhoffen hätte können und die skandale
in der politik die korruptionsskandale
in der politik naja wenn es danach ginge
dann müsste deutschland auch um die
mitgliedschaft bangen denke ich in der
diskussion jetzt eröffnet
bitte herr lang also auf ihre frage von
gerade eben noch mal wie geht es dann
eigentlich weiter nehmen wir mal an wir
haben eine situation ich sage mal den
brüchigen stabilität und dann wird
natürlich im vordergrund stehen der
wiederaufbau des landes die europäische
union hat ja jetzt auch in groben zügen
skizziert wie solch ein solcher
wiederaufbauplan aussehen könnte was
komponenten lehrern und im sinne von
bild bag bergretter jetzt breiten
formulieren würde ich möchte dazu sagen
keine modernisieren und da wird ein
interessanter punkt sein dass man sagt
wir nutzen die ganzen mittel die in die
ukraine fließen werden um das land zu
europäisieren um es so zu sagen eu ready
zu machen große frage für mich in dem
zusammenhang
damit die eu den reformdruck sagen
flügel fall heilen kann stellte sie
bedingungen konditionalität ist der
jargon begriff und jetzt müssen wir uns
fragen möchte man eigentlich harte
bedingungen stellen damit die korruption
bekämpft wird wenn er viele milliarden
fließen werden oder sagt man in
bestimmten bereichen machen würde es
nicht wenn wir einfach ein interesse
daran haben dass brücken dass schulen
wieder aufgebaut das ist also glaube ich
dass es etwas was sozusagen in nächster
zeit dann nach einem krieg im
vordergrund stehen würde und die frage
inwieweit man das synchronisieren kann
mit dem prozess der heranführung an die
eu dann noch etwas grundsätzlicheres zum
erweiterungs zur erweiterungspolitik der
europäischen union ich glaube da gibt es
zwei logik ja die eigene logik die haben
sie sehr stark in den vordergrund
gestellt im grunde nach dem alten
prinzip die effektivste außenpolitik die
europäische union hat war erweiterungen
ja da konnten wir gestalten und
ordnungspolitik machen die andere logik
ist die integrationspolitik also
verträgt die europäische union mit blick
auf ihre handlungsfähigkeit auf ihre
funktionsfähigkeit eigentlich die
hereinnahme von immer mehr ländern und
die ukraine ist ein großes land ist ein
warum das land das ist nicht trivial
glaube ich insofern braucht es natürlich
schon nannte das früher mal
absorptionsfähigkeit einer debatte über
die politik folgen die das hätte wenn
man die reine frage noch erstellen wie
ist es um die rechtsstaatlichkeit der
ukraine bestellt also frau liter cola
gerade meine verhalten zurückgewiesen
wie ist es um die rechte das ist ja ein
wichtiges thema das nicht bisher immer
so verstanden auch in der innenkabine
jetzt nicht während des krieges aber in
der zeit davor ist das ja wieder immer
wieder als thematisiert worden der
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der ukraine also
ich glaube auf der auf der habenseite
können wir sicherlich verbuchen es gibt
gesellschaftliche pluralismus es gab
freie wahlen mit ein paar vielleicht
fragezeichen aber im grundsatz waren
diese wahlen frei es gibt medien
pluralität und anderes mehr so glaube
ich die defizite
gegen das ist der bereich der guten
regierungsführung
also der seilschaften der korruption das
thema was der lenski sich auf die fahnen
geschrieben hat der d-liga visierung wie
kann man eigentlich sozusagen diese
leute die teilweise in staat und kopiert
hatten rausdrängen ja ist da
möglicherweise
die situation nach dem krieg besonders
schlecht oder ist sie besonders gut weil
man auf die reset taste drücken kann
also wie kann man sagen diese gruppen
interessengruppen die in teilen der
elite verankert sind eigentlich
herausdrängen und wenn wir uns auf
korruptions auf die üblichen korruption
rankings zu dem man sagen kann was man
will aber gucken da ist sozusagen die
ukraine am ganz unteren ende in europa
russland ist natürlich noch schlimmer
aber da ist noch einiges zu tun jetzt
muss man natürlich auch realpolitisch
argumentieren wenn wir sehr strenge
kriterien anlegen würden ja dann wird
die kleinen juni mehr beitreten ja es
braucht sozusagen eine klare
konditionalität aber das problem bei
diesen kriterien die die eu aus gutem
grunde definiert die kopenhagener
kriterien die die voraussetzung für den
beitritt sind ist sie können natürlich
politisiert werden und länder die den
beitritt nicht wollen können halt auf
die bremse treten wenn sie der
auffassung da stimmt doch was nicht da
geht noch was nicht also alles wie wie
kann ein reform momentum erzeugt werden
erreicht dadurch dann der
kandidatenstatus tatsächlich aus
nachbarn wäre dann hätten wir eine
situation in der wir ganz ihrer meinung
dass es sozusagen noch sehr sehr sehr
sehr lange dauern wird bis die ukraine
auch nur kandidaten status erreichen
würde nur leben wenn ich in einer
solchen zeit sondern wir leben in einer
zeit einer ganz grundsätzlichen
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
in der europa tatsächlich bedroht wird
und ich glaube wenn jetzt und das wollte
ich noch wohin sagen es nicht die
kommission die hier eigentlich
entscheides ist der rat die kommission
wird jetzt demnächst ihre empfehlung
abgeben über
die erteilung eines kandidatenstatus und
man muss karat im grunde um entscheiden
das wird er wahrscheinlich ende juni tun
aber nichtsdestoweniger sollte die
kommission tatsächlich eine solche
empfehlung abgeben und sollte sich der
rat dieser empfehlung dann anschließen
und tatsächlich die ukraine zum
kandidaten machen dann glaube ich dass
sie dahinter nicht mehr zurückkommen das
heißt ein stecken bleiben wie wir zum
beispiel zwar sehr bei der türkei
gesehen haben ist dann glaube ich nicht
mehr möglich weil einfach diese
sicherheitspolitische herausforderungen
so stark ist und ein letzter punkt
vielleicht noch viele reden immer davon
wir könnten das ganze mich machen schon
mit 27 wäre die eu ja nicht mehr
entscheidungsfähig man das liegt auch
makros politischer gemeinschaft zu
grunde aber die frage ist wie kommen wir
da raus wenn wir darauf warten wollen
dieses video tatsächlich interne
reformen anstößt um aus dem
einstimmigkeitsprinzip raus zu kommen
dann sollten wir allen möglichen
beitrittskandidaten sagen sie sollen
sich erstmal eine andere regionale
organisationen suchen die europäische
union schafft in den nächsten 100 jahren
nicht vielleicht ist die strategie jetzt
tatsächlich diese kandidaten
hereinzuholen in die europäische union
genau das richtige also die situation so
deutlich unregierbar zu machen dass der
druck zur reform auch innerhalb der
union endlich so weit strenger es ist
noch nichts unterschrieben
habe ich sie richtig verstanden in
europa in not ist dann gilt im zweifel
bei der mitglieds frage
geschwindigkeit vor kündigt weil er
nicht richtig sind jetzt zwei
unterschiedliche dinge das eine ist
sozusagen tatsächlich der
kandidatenstatus dann können überhaupt
erst beitrittsverhandlungen aufgenommen
werden und dann müssen wir 35 kapitel
durchgegangen werden ich glaube
geschwindigkeit vor gründlichkeit könnte
nur was den kandidatenstatus jetzt an
geht passiert und danach müssen die
kapitel selbstverständlich
durchgearbeitet werden und
selbstverständlich hat die ukraine auch
noch ein paar gravierende defizite wie
sie auch noch bearbeiten muss und dafür
brauchte es um das zu beschleunigen
einmal sie haben das genannt das
wiederaufbauprogramm nach dem krieg und
durch den eu-beitritt können wir jetzt
tatsächlich diejenigen teile der
ukrainischen eliten die pro demokratisch
eingestellt sind soweit stärken und zu
uns locken das ist eben auch gelingen
kann diesen weg tatsächlich zügig zu
beschreiten unsere guten was ich sagen
wollte war dazu zu im blick als letzten
punkt ich denke
kandidatenstatus wird der instrumente
geben diese gelder dir einfließen wie
wiederaufbau viel besser zu
kontrollieren und ich will dazu sagen
wir sprechen hier immer wieder merke ich
wie die subjektivität der ukraine der
ukraine abgesprochen wird ja wie denn
putin was will denn makro wie können wir
die ukraine in die eu führen wir können
die wir die ukraine dazu zwingen die
reformen durchzuführen wie können wir
die ukraine dazu zwingen korruption zu
bekämpfen
korruptionsbekämpfung ist eine der
populärsten ideen in der ukrainischen
gesellschaft tatsächlich die
zivilgesellschaft in der ukraine ist
wahnsinnig aktiv und wahnsinnig stark
und er sind alle daran interessiert dass
ihr eigentlich diese idee von ihr noch
2014 viele leute haben gesagt warum
wollte in die eu bei umfragen war
ständig die antwort dann können wir
besser dann wird er uns helfen
unsere regierung dazu zwingen die
korruption zu bekämpfen also
korruptionsbekämpfung ist eine populäre
idee und eu beitritt wird unterstützt
von 90 prozent der bevölkerung heute wo
es an jeder ecke der eu brücken wo
findet man so ein tolles land wo 90
prozent der bevölkerung eu fans sind und
keine skeptiker das ist doch auch was
gutes
gute ukraine
die popularität der eu anti näher man
kommt schon in den verhandlungen wenn
die schwierigen dossier her oft gedacht
werden bröckelt das und danach und her
gibt es ja auch beispiele in den
langwierigen erweiterten ich würde gerne
nochmal zu dem aspekt absicherung der
ukraine bei der integration nach europa
dem drang nach europa auch irgendwann
mal mitglied der europäischen
so werden die militärische absicherung
der bundeskanzler war gestern in im
baltikum gewesen in litauen da ist nicht
so wahnsinnig freundlich empfangen
worden weil man dort ähnlich wie in der
ukraine oder in polen auch deutschland
im verdacht hat sie wirken nicht so
wirklich richtig der ukraine zumindest
das militärisch helfen worten er hat
jetzt als geschenk mitgebracht olaf
scholz dass diese private jahr weiter
ausgebaut werden soll diese drei bis
5000 mann im nächsten jahr auch von
deutschland geführt wobei die
bayerischen regierungschefin ändern
sagten ja aber nicht nur in einem land
sondern wir brauchen das in jedem land
eine blockade von drei bis fünf 1000
nato-soldaten die sehr gut bewaffnet
sind um russland von dummheiten
abzuhalten und eben auch um einen
möglichen integrationsprozess in der
ukraine richtung westen militärisch
abzusichern ist das eine realistische
dimension kann man damit auch der die
ukraine auch absichern gegenüber
möglichen machtgelüsten putins naja es
ist ja eine konsequenz des russischen
überfall auf die ukraine nicht dass man
jetzt die nato ostflanke stärkt und in
diesem kontext muss man auch das sehen
was jetzt im baltikum läuft und das ist
erst der anfang also wenn es tatsächlich
in eine kalte krieg szenario geht dann
haben wir eine vorne verteidigung wie im
kalten krieg noch weiter ostwärts und
dann wird deutschland auch nicht umhin
kommen 500 mann mehr zu stellen sondern
wir werden am ende wenn es in dieses
szenario geht eine ganze division an der
ostgrenze polens haben das 20.000 so da
war ja aber mindestens nicht und wir
werden im grunde werden werden polen
balten rumänen auch von uns das fordern
was wir auch von den westlichen
alliierten im kalten krieg bekommen
haben und das ist auf jeden fall ein
commitment was sehr realitätsnah ist und
das muss man ja auch in dem kontext
jetzt sehen diese sondervermögens für
die bundeswehr das wir dringend die
einsatzbereitschaft der streitkräfte
hochfahren müssen die ja gar nicht
gegeben ist also die bund hält
deutschland in einer ähnlichen situation
wie die ukraine wäre blank zitat des
inspekteur des heeres nicht so konnte
ich gar nicht dass ich und das ist
natürlich auch das problem das durch
geht bis in die waffenlieferung und
nicht die haben ja selber nichts nicht
wir haben das vor kurzem weniger
kampfpanzer als die schweiz
unsere streitkräfte in einem dramatisch
schlechten zustand nicht und vor allen
dingen was ukraine anfangen wenn ich das
vergleiche vor allem in der mindset der
ukraine die die bereitschaft haben für
ihr land zu kämpfen mit der waffe in der
hand suchen sie das mal in deutschland
ich möchte keine umfrage machen wer
überhaupt dazu bereit ist das heißt wir
haben hier eine andere situation und wir
haben ja auch eine riesenbaustelle auch
in unserem eigenen land und dieser
konflikt russland ukraine erinnert uns
an diese baustellen und die müssen war
bearbeitet ein antrag gestellt sie waren
ja werde ich die letzten wochen monate
dass er ja eigentlich gegen die
lieferung von schweren waffen in die
ukraine gewesen wir haben ja eine ganze
reihe von schwerem gerät auf dem hof
stehen zum teil bei den rüstungsfirmen
zum teil dort doch auf dem schrottplatz
so das hat mit einem mit einer
panzerkette sozusagen auf dem
schrottplatz all das kann man jetzt
wieder aktivieren macht es in diesem
zusammenhang was sie gesagt haben auch
sinn dann in der tat die ukraine ob
jetzt durch ringtausch oder irgendetwas
anderes militärisch zu ertüchtigen also
ich habe wirklich ein problem mit den
schweren waffen aus vielerlei gründen
ein grund ist einfach die militärische
effizienz nicht sie brauchen sie sind
sehr ausbildungs intensiv auch der gap
hat dieser flugabwehr panzer dass ein
hochkomplexes waffensystem kampfpanzer
leopard auch
das brauche logistik ersatzteile
ersatzteilversorgung und dann natürlich
das thema der verlegung also wie soll
das denn laufen die sind
eisenbahntransport mitteleuropa 2000
kilometer durch die west ukraine ein
bisschen der ost ukraine also ich weiß
nicht wie das funktionieren soll und das
problem ist bekommt jetzt auch auf
deutschland zu wir haben entschieden
panzerhaubitzen flugabwehr panzer eben
zu liefern jetzt sind politische
entscheidungen gefällt jetzt sickerte
immer mehr durch wie lange das dauert
vor weihnachten ich weiß es geht zwar
schafft ist das wird wochen und monate
dauern weil diese ganzen der technischen
fragen auch dahinter stehen und ich und
die ukraine haben in ihrer verteidigung
große erfolge auch gegen schweres gerät
ich meine die haben jede menge russische
panzer schützenpanzer neutralisierten
moderne panzerabwehrwaffen diese
geliefert bekommen haben
flugabwehrwaffen mit drohnen kampfdrohne
nicht und das sind eigentlich die
instrumente die sie auch brauchen nicht
ich sehe nicht die situation dass man in
der ost ukraine jetzt den großen
gepanzerten gegenangriff fährt zur
befreiung des donbass es wird nicht
funktionieren weil die manpower matte
aus aber wir haben es mit einer anderen
kriegssituation zu tun wir haben es
jetzt mit einer massierung der
russischen kräfte zu tun die gewalt am
stück vorgehen und das ist einfach eine
komplett andere situation mit der es zu
tun und da brauchen wir schwere darunter
stimme kommen der bemannten drohen nicht
mehr hinten sondern ganz ehrlich es sind
auch schon andere schwere waffen in die
ukraine geliefert worden also sie können
noch nicht sagen das hängt bitte an den
schienenwegen das ist auch das hängt
schon daran aber es sind einige heimlich
university schwere waffen von den russen
neutralisiert wurden erbeutet worden so
viele sind ja wir haben überhaupt keinen
das machen da zahlen darüber wie viele
ist hat sein
russland meldet sie irgendwie sind aber
überhaupt nicht bestätigt gleichzeitig
kommen nach wie vor waffen in dieses
land das eigentlich das unüberwindbare
hindernisse das ist mir ganz wichtig und
vielleicht der eine punkt noch die
deutschen streitkräfte mögen tatsächlich
defizite in vielen bereichen haben aber
einsatzbereit sind sie das können sie
allein daraus sehen wie viele einsätze
die deutschen streitkräfte in den
letzten jahren immer noch gemacht haben
trotz der schlechten ausrüstung die sie
immerhin hat muss also
einsatzbereitschaft ist da mein einsatz
wichtig kein neues vielleicht doch das
ist eigentlich einsatzbereitschaft und
die einsatzfähigkeit ist wir waren ja
sehr stark auf afghanistan fokussiert 20
jahre und ich habe das selber erlebt und
wir haben die landesverteidigung
natürlich hinten angestellt das hat sich
jetzt geändert durch den russischen
überfall auf die ukraine das ist jetzt
die neue lage und dafür sind wir nicht
vorbereitet habe keinen depots wir haben
keine munition wir haben munition für
zwei drei tage im moment deswegen machen
wir das sondervermögen nein also bitte
die situation der deutschen streitkräfte
ist sehr schlecht die munition kommt aus
dem ganz normalen haushalt sie wird
nicht als 21 milliarden etwa nur für
munition das ist ein wahnsinns volumen
gleich und das sondervermögen ist wird
auch die bundeswehr alleine nicht
einsatzbereit machen und wir werden
jahre brauchen ist das so ist und das
muss man auch den ukrainischen freundin
deutlich machen weil ich mehr geht nach
dir reden aneinander vorbei wenn ich
über bereitschaft rede dann meine ich
sozusagen den willen der streitkräfte
tatsächlich einsätze zu führen und das
haben wir gesehen dass haben die
deutschen streitkräfte die fähigkeiten
das ist etwas anderes weil wir ihm über
bestimmte gerät schaffen und
ausrüstungsgegenstände nicht mehr ein
hinreichender zahl oder nicht mehr
sozusagen einsatz
willen haben wenn sie die fähigkeit
nicht haben bringt ich will auch nicht
elf jahre war marie und afghanistan
sprechen heute starte ich kann
eigentlich nur sagen dass ich höre dass
wir das alles geschafft hat mit dieser
ausrüstung schafft wir sind aus
afghanistan abgezogen sein
dass wir amerikaner dabei hatten das
sonst wäre das gar nicht gelaufen diese
evakuierungen dieses thema eines
untersuchungsausschusses ist was wir da
geleistet haben das war kein ruhmesblatt
wir waren 20 jahre gab es gar nichts
ich will das thema auf dann ist ein
gutes thema weil aus meiner sicht
militärisch gesehen rein militärisch
operativ gesehen hat die ukraine dann
eine chance wenn sie diesen konflikt
verlängert nicht wenn sie eben nicht auf
die entscheidungsschlacht setzt mit der
sie gegen diese maschine der russen auch
nichts ausrichten können wenn sie einen
zustand erreichen den wir in afghanistan
erlebt haben wir sind am ende geschlagen
wurden von von taliban kämpfern auf
mopeds in turnschuhen und kalaschnikows
nicht mit schweren waffen die amerikaner
sind aus irak rausgegangen nicht weil
das schwere waffen aufgetaucht wären die
russen hier sollte jetzt mussten
afghanistan verlassen nicht wegen der
schweren waffen also ich will damit
sagen der kampfwille die kampf
motivation ist das ist schon richtig ein
hoher faktor welches kommt da weniger
auf die waffen an sondern eher auf diese
dieser motivation und das ist aus meiner
sicht die entscheidende möglichkeit
letztlich der der der ukraine wenn es
ihnen gelingt eben nicht panzer gegen
panzer schützenpanzer gegen
schützenpanzer sie werden das nicht
schaffen weil auch die russen ihre
logistische basis hinter sich haben die
ukraine da sind 800 bis 1000 kilometer
zu überbrücken wie wird die russen haben
die luft herrschaft nicht kontrollieren
die nachschubwege ich wir können froh
sein wenn wir das eine oder andere gerät
durch bekommen noch weil ich ich würde
gerne zum wir haben noch drei minuten
zum ende der sendung noch mal ganz genau
an europäische union verlangt wenn man
jetzt die ukraine wir haben ja jetzt
gehört was dafür spricht diesem land
schnell eine perspektive zu geben
oder auch georgien und moldawien also
eine vorzugsbehandlung
zukommen lässt was sagen denn dann die
anderen sollen die namen sind schon
genannt haben die anderen
beitrittskandidaten also albanien und
mazedonien montenegro serbien die sind
ja alle in der pipeline wie werden die
da reagieren entsteht ein neuer konflikt
die haben schon reagiert indem sie
sagten müssen wir erst wieder
bombardiert werden damit dass
fortschritt geben wird aber ich glaube
der kandidatenstatus wird nicht das
entscheidende sein das entscheidende
wird dann sein was was danach passiert
letzten endes ich fand es interessant
also unser thema ist die mögliche eu
mitgliedschaft der ukraine und wir sind
wieder bei waffenlieferungen und den
zustand der möglicherweise wenig zählen
aber zum fall er ist kein zufall denn
die grundsatzfrage die herausforderung
vor der die eu letztlich steht ist wer
stellt das öffentliche gut sicherheit
für die ukraine da die eu kann das sind
gelder der ukraine liefern die eu kann
sagen wohlstand produzieren aber sie
kann keinen schutz geben das war auch
schon in der vergangenheit so ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass russland
passiv zuschauen wird wenn sich der
annäherungsprozess der ukraine an die eu
materialisiert 2014 die beiden prozesse
proteste und russlands zu sagt
interventionen danach hatten wir etwas
mit dem assoziierungsabkommen zu tun die
europäische union wurde nicht intendiert
zu einem geopolitischen akteur im nach
sowjetischen raum und ist für russland
ein konkurrent und eindringling und
russland wird darauf reagieren dieses
thema wird uns wahrscheinlich noch lange
beschäftigen vor israel coulin sie haben
die letzte frage beziehungsweise haben
das letzte wort hier es wird ja hier der
diskutiert soll die ukraine den krieg
gewinnen oder soll sie ihn nicht
verlieren eine etwas seltsame diskussion
was es bedeutet sieg über russland für
die ukraine was was ist das was bedeutet
das für das selbstverständnis und für
die nation der ukraine je nach dass der
krieg eben siegreich für die ukraine
ausgeht ich werde noch kurz sagen dass
die ukraine die kriterien für den
kandidatenstatus erfüllt und das ist
doch soll doch reich sind dafür dass die
aufgenommen wird und natürlich muss die
ukraine gewinnen weil wenn die ukraine
nicht gewinnt dann wird russland nicht
aufhören ihren willen der welt und
europa auf kostete nachbarländern
diktieren zu sagen weil die ukraine auch
kämpfen dass dieses das hängt auch von
eu nato staaten ab das hängt davon ab
wie bereit die nato staaten und die eu
sind zu helfen und echte hilfe zu
leisten und mehr als floskeln und gebete
zu bieten
dann bedanke ich mich soweit diese
diskussion wird katharina bohlen mit
nicole seiten hof mit erich fahrt und
mit carola iv lange bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]